ouais s Lake ouais allons-y, ce serait peut-être
mieux il y a beaucoup trop de vert
il y a beaucoup de rouge et certains de ces
doigts là tu as raison allons
au S Lake et c'est en direction de l'
aéroport de toute façon
alors tu vas bien Thompson I  je suis bien je suis
toujours bien tu sais ce que je veux
dire tout comme
toi
aucune raison de ne pas être
bien
je reste un peu à gauche ici parce que
c'est plus coloré ouais ouais
merci
car
ça va être sympa parce que
sur le lac à droite  devant nous [ __ ] ouais il y
a un reflet d'euh
arbres verts bien euh
arbres rouges tu les vois je ne peux pas ouais
j'essaie juste de l'amener alors on va
là où il y a plus de couleur
ouais merde
quelque part il faut que Shadow  être dans la
photo quelque part Ombre non non non non non
où est-il je ne sais pas où c'est je
pense que ça va finir par être hors de la tour
juste un peu, hein,
je ne le vois pas, d'accord, je ne le vois pas  soit
perdu, je vois que c'est la tour, c'est
vrai, oh, c'est à droite ouais, gu, c'est
parti là-bas, dirige-toi vers le reflet de l'ombre rouge
ouais, je suis
le reflet rouge, tu veux avoir celui sur la pointe ou tu
veux avoir celui tout droit devant
celui du bas, pas celui en bas à
droite de la pointe ici sur la pointe non,
pas la
pointe en fait Pete, je vais me tourner un
peu vers ma droite peut-être 20 degrés,
il y en a un plus gros, quelques plus gros
dedans, ouais, tu vois  ces deux gros
ensemble, voilà, allez-y, ouais, qu'est-ce
qui va arriver à l'ombre
ici, mais de toute façon, elle n'apparaîtra pas
très bien dans l'eau, elle apparaîtra sur les
arbres au fur et à mesure que nous les aurons,
je vais vous dire quoi  Je vais passer à
droite ouais pour que tu puisses
avoir la caméra juste à gauche
d'accord et on n'aura pas
ça devrait marcher hein
ouais il y en a une très belle rouge à
l'extrémité sud de celles-ci
ouais
ok, comment ça a marché ouais
ouais la lumière baisse enfin une fois qu'elle
commence, elle descend vite, on dirait un St
euh, dois-je refaire un cercle euh peut-être
autour des arbres rouges à l'intérieur euh Peter à
9h00 tu le vois ouais ouais c'est  dans le
ouais, exactement CL monte un peu plus haut parce que je
pense que ça ira mieux si je grimpe un
peu donc ça a l'air sympa ouais mais regarde en
grimpant, ça va devenir un peu, est-ce que
je pense que nous devenons plus nets quand je
le grimpe  ce serait bien d'avoir une très belle
photo de
reflet, j'en ai une dernière, il y a beaucoup de
rouge, la couleur pourrait être un peu meilleure
plus près de la rive,
je ne sais pas s'il y a quelque chose là-bas
ou
non, savez-vous à quoi ça ressemble mieux  c'est que
si nous longeons le rivage, regardons
le rivage, d'accord, puis longeons le
sinus si vous le
pouvez, ma bombe est une photo,
où est cette ombre dans la photo, est-ce euh, je
ne la vois pas maintenant, vous ne pouvez vraiment pas
la voir mais c'est  là
quelque part, ça a l'air mieux ouais ouais
c'est pas si net le rouge ne
sort pas encore ça ne sort pas
vraiment nos ombres au sommet des
arbres
ici d'accord je recule la section des
arbres n'est pas si nette  non oh Ondule le
côté du lac qu'est-il arrivé au soleil,
il est presque devenu de la brume, n'est-ce pas, ce que
le soleil est entré dans de la
brume à l'horizon, il a perdu sa
définition ouais, ok,
arrête de rouler, ouais, regarde juste un peu
de reflet  sur
et
comme beaucoup de jamais rouges ou pas pas
beaucoup de
rouges rouges maintenant de retour le
h
un joli rouge
regarde cette maison sous l'eau
ouais je ne m'attends pas à un
tsunami c'est assez pointu
de toute façon, n'est-ce pas, nous y allons en quelques rouges pas un
beaucoup de rouges et de jaunes ici, tu
sais, tu les vois ouais tu roules euh oui je
le suis
ouais oh ici il y a du rouge rouge et du
jaune je pense que nous allons tout droit le long de cette
brillance, nous aurons probablement des rouges et
des jaunes il y a des
maisons oh un Shad en plein milieu de
nous devons être là, c'est bien stop
stop stop stop stop stop